[Music]
well
I don't know me
and
[Music]
in these layers
then I'm going for him
when they go for the thick food
of africa
strange today from the same families
[Music]
here
ah
bananas
and
big guy  unknown but the topic comes
here
i
inhabitant does not fall for you like this
[Music]
pain
with work enjoy
[Music]
she forgave me
already issues
like there are now
and
very
[Music]
she
has married
[Music]
yes
like that
ah
sui
yes
[  Music]
[Music
] nobody
here
[Music]
the aromatic two people the fiber at the same
time
yes
their formations
let's say
ah
[Music]
and
be adults in a way of being
hello good morning could you give me a punk
by way please and we are a  30
percent flour
[Music]
yes
thank you
very much thank you very much perfect thank you very much
[Music] they
go like a cusco recipe
how soft and crispy at the same time
delicious
[Music]
that part
records for
the ambient of great there
[Music]